I'm working why would I want to go out
with you this is like the worst place to
ask someone no I don't want to go out
with anyone who asked me out at work hi
my name is glory and I currently work at
Apple hi my name is David a former Apple
store employee hey my name is Brian
Molina I am a former Apple employee and
today we're gonna be playing never have
I ever never have I ever given a
discount to someone because I thought
they were cute I have not yeah somebody
you know really attractive came into the
store they wanted an extra 10% discount
usually we give those to family members
so he kind of had to say that they were
a cousin when you kind of go into like
your shift you know which managers are
going to be on the floor if it's a good
day and you can get away with a few
things nice broth like once maybe twice
never have I ever helped a customer who
brought in a product that was clearly
fake I haven't no like I didn't actually
like help them like I saw that it was
fake I was like can't touch this I don't
even think I've had any fake phones come
in I have done that I have done that
only just to kind of prove them wrong
that this isn't working because this
isn't a real thing and it happens
probably more often it should and people
think they're slick but Apple employees
we're trained trained for these things
never have I ever jailbroken my iPhone
or someone else's no I have not done
that I haven't mostly because I have no
idea
fully what that means I've done it all
the time just so I can get the latest
iOS without you know having to wait for
it to come out in September I'm just
trying to get cooled wallpapers and
updates and stuff like that at least
from what I've seen it's not that common
that people jailbreak their phone
anymore so I don't see the point
never have I ever pretended not to know
how to fix something because
all the time all the time oh yeah
any employable business people used to
come in they used to just be angry and
upset especially when they're like older
and they don't listen to you I don't
want to help them so people be nice it
doesn't hurt you never have I ever
airdrop something to the wrong person by
accident nope I haven't done that I have
not cuz you know sometimes like it's
very deceptive like an ear job pops up
and then you think about to click it and
then like three pop up at the same time
so you click the next one by accident
it's like some stranger what happens a
lot in this store actually is that if
they see people's names on airdrop they
just send it to everyone and sometimes
some of the things that we use like for
teaching classes have airdrop turned on
and so they get put on their bad stuff
no not that I've seen I'm sure it's
happened but not anything that I've seen
never have I ever up sold someone for a
product they didn't need I am NOT yes I
have not I haven't no I haven't done
that if somebody doesn't want something
I'm not I'm not gonna do it they didn't
want I didn't want and I wasn't gonna
force them customers are funny
especially when they have more money
they kind of expect to be up sold and
I'm like no that's all you need and
they're like that's is like that that is
all you need if you want something else
I can get it for you but yeah and that's
something I think that I appreciate it
on Apple they kind of like ingrained
that in your head a little bit never
have I ever asked someone out or been
asked out while on the job I have
definitely been asked out on the job but
it's very annoying yes that's a good
like details do it always started out as
you know they had an issue with their
phone without an issue with the computer
and then they would you know slowly get
into the flirting and the touching and
the giggles and then you kind of know
where it's going from there I've never
asked out anyone but I have been asked
out I'm working why would I want to go
out with you this is like the worst
place to ask someone no I don't want to
go out with anyone who asked me out at
work never have I ever told someone you
were out of a certain product but
actually
or yeah I have
nope
I haven't done that either because it
doesn't benefit me in any kind of way
they're here to get something and then
leave let's do that to the you can you
can leave yeah this I've only done this
like twice someone comes in like last
five minutes of the store closing hey I
want to switch from this carrier to this
carrier and I want two phones and I want
to add my kids to it like were sold out
so yes I have and I don't regret it
never have I ever given fake advice to a
customer because I didn't know how to
fix something nope I've done that either
because when I just don't know I'm like
I have no idea because this problem when
I first started working there you don't
really know a lot so I would just make
up things on the fly basically and I
would just kind of like flip through
apps
I like swipe through things and then you
like open into another app and then
you're just like there you go most of
the times it would work out we're here
you know I was able to just get by it
and they were able to figure it out
themselves I never have I ever
recommended an Android no never
very true I would never recommend an
inverter to anybody just because I don't
like them and I think they sec own house
Wernick and she's like a black sheep of
the family I won't talk to you now we're
all your green bubbles so yeah I would
never recommend an Android I would
always stand by a bull regardless if I'm
working there now or was working before
love Apple always would love that
[Music]
[Music]